Using a dog coil. How do you determine the correct frequencies? You can waste years playing around with the wrong ones.
Well, a dog coil is usually sold as a frequency generator, frequency machine to help kill pathogens in Lyme disease. It's very common in the Lyme community.
But in truth, a dog coil is not really a rife machine. So how I define a rife machine. So a rife machine is a frequency generator that uses light frequencies. A dog coil to my understanding is really more of electrical generator, which makes it fall into the category of a pulsed electromagnetic field therapy equipment.
So it's more of a P E M F, which is great. But then you're not, you're not really concerned about the frequencies. You don't have much play in with a P E M F to play with the different frequencies. I know different P E M F's you can use different certain different frequencies. But it's in a range that isn't going to be.
It isn't going to kill pathogens. So what the purpose of a P E M F machine is to help stimulate your cell membranes helps stimulate your immune system. You're all your cell membranes hold a charge. So your cells have a membrane around them and they have a charge that is actually measurable. You can actually measure that charge with some different pieces of equipment.
And as a person's cell charge goes down, their health gets worse and worse. There's articles written on this. There is much research in the cancer field with looking at a person's phasing. That's what a measurement of somebody's cell charge is.
And as that person goes through a series of care, typically most cancer research is done while a person is going through, you know, chemotherapy or a course of standards of care.
If their phase angle remained level through that course of care, their chance of survival was much higher than somebody whose phase angle or cell charge was dropping significantly.
So often what a person is ill, they'll have a lower cell charge with phase angles measured from zero to about the highest I've seen is about 12.
And a normal cell charge or a normal phase angle on a person is about, you want it to be over 6.6.0. I had people that were fairly healthy even in their 70s that were in the 7s.
I used to treat some of the Minnesota Vikings players that had a cell charge over 10. If you're younger, you're going to have a much higher cell charge.
But as we age our cell charge or phase angle drops and as we are become sick for whatever reason our cell charge could drops our phase angle will drop. But if we go if our cell charge is staying level or going up through a series of care, your survival rate is much higher.
Well, that is a huge benefit of the PEMF including a dog coil machine can help people through survival methods through cancer through Lyme disease because it helps increase one's phase angle.
So that can be very helpful. Well, how does that really help? Well, if you increase somebody's phase angle, you're increasing the health of their cell membranes.
If you increase the health of the cell membranes, you increase the health of the cell. So inside of each cell in your body is literally like equivalent to New York City. I have everything that's going on in New York City. It's taking place inside your cell.
You have thousands of different organelles and you have of course a nucleus, which you have DA, which then replicate in order to make a new cell.
The DNA also codes for making enzymes, making proteins, all sorts of different things that you need for that cell to survive, and that cell to do its job, whatever that cell is if it's a muscle cell or heart cell or whatever it is.
So the health of the cell membrane is utmost importance to the health of what could go on inside that cell. So as far as getting back to the question, how do you know the frequencies to use with a person, it depends on what you're trying to do.
So we don't use dog coil machines in our office. We use a different type of right machine called a true right machine, which is very easy to program literally whatever frequency you want to run within the program of the machine.
So there are no frequencies for different diseases. So let's say if you have prostate cancer, you would want to run just the node frequencies for prostate cancer.
You may want to run frequencies for other co-morbidities that you might have with prostate cancer, maybe inflammation, maybe you have metastasis to hold, you want some bold building frequencies.
You may have issues with detoxification pathways like everybody that asks you if I want to run some liver frequencies or key frequencies.
But you build that around what's needed for the patient. So there are frequency charts that are available to the public.
You could even Google write frequencies. There's documents that are PDF documents that show different frequencies.
Again, I don't think you'll be able to really use your dog coil with these frequencies, but if you had a GB 4000 or a true right, you could program those frequencies.
That's why what a person comes to us and let's say they have a specific disease or cancer that will write a specific program that they'll run literally all night long.
Because these frequencies aren't magic. And it's one big mistake that people make when they use a right machine or or a PDF, they think that using it for 20 to 30 to 60 minutes a day is going to cure them of their
Evaluity, and that's just not true. You're hitting the body with those frequencies so that you can stimulate a response in the case of trying to kill a pathogen with light frequencies, you can kill a pathogen directly that when you're dealing with like cancer, you're not killing directly.
A cancer cell is your own cell and it's much sturdier for a sake of a better word than a single cell organism like a bacteria.
So you're not going to kill directly. You're not going to cause lysis of the cell when you hit it with when you hit a cancer cell with the frequencies that you're trying to disturb the cancer cell.
What you are doing when you use right technology light frequencies to help kill cancer, you're stimulating that cancer cells who are in my right so that your immune system will now take another look at it because that's a huge problem with cancer is that cancer is not an outside organism.
Cancer is your old cells that something got in the cell, damaged the nucleus and caused it to go into rapid replication and it's replicated cells that are also damaged, damaged nuclei in rapid replication. That's what cancer is.
That's one cell that started rapid replicating and continue and continue and continue knowing of this, you know, mass of cells that are damaged, damaged nuclei and are in a state of rapid replication, but they're still self tissue.
Now your immune system is not supposed to destroy self tissue, you have a fail safe mechanism for your T cells and your natural killer cells to not destroy self tissue, so you have to get the immune system to look at this cancer over and over and over and over again until it sees it as an enemy and will destroy it.
And that's the benefit of using the right you're stimulating those cancer cells so they vibrate so it's an irritation in the body so your immune system will look at it to try to kill it.
So there are no frequencies for many many many different pathogens, there's no frequencies for different cancers and those are the things that we do in programming a right machine.
So I do agree you could have a greatest tool in the world, like a frequency generator, if you're not running the right frequencies for your malady, it's not going to help.
So I think the two best right machines on the market are the GB 4000, which is much more difficult to use so we don't typically use that and the true right which is much easier to use and easier to program.
But again, you can run a true right for, let's say a prostate cancer, again, if you're running the wrong frequencies, it's going to do nothing to your prostate cancer.
So if you're running just some general cancer frequency set that maybe you got went from the company or from a practitioner who isn't real experienced, well, it's going to have little good, you know, it's going to do little good.
We could ever do harm, but you're going to do little good and well, that doesn't help.